Gary's in South Carolina hey Gary how
are you hey I'm doing great Dave hope
you it hopefully you guys are too I I do
have a question but before I ask my
question I actually want to thank you
because my wife and I were sitting
around having our coffee yesterday
morning and we were thinking about just
how blessed we are because we are 100%
debt-free and this is a stressful
situation but when you ain't got no
bills you got a lot less stress and we
we learned all this stuff the hard way
about 25 years ago and we took your
class FPU when you still taught it
yourself at Christ Church oh my goodness
in the early 90s so yeah with an
overhead projector it changed us and
it's been a real blessing but to my
question we do have a small business
several employees and the business has
run completely debt-free for about 13
years now we have cash in the bank
problem is when you're shut down and and
legally we cannot open and the governor
shut down all non-essential businesses
and they did not say when they would
reopen or allow us to reopen and it's
indefinite probably a first could be in
to me by then we could have burned
through what cash reserves we have to
pay everybody and keep the bills paid so
we're looking at let's see what you
thought about like the the CID L or the
TPP grants through the government or
loans whatever they're calling them and
because at the burn rate we got we can
probably hang on for six or eight weeks
but it'll be over yeah
well number one I'm not gonna tell you
to borrow money there do that you know
the SBA loans that are supposedly going
to be forgiven are fraught with several
problems one is the number one they're
they're obviously a loan and you're
dealing with the SBA which both of those
things mean they're not going to happen
fast the banks are getting showered with
requests already
but the SBA is just not an organization
that has the ability nor the inclination
to move fast the second problem is is
that it this is a loan that has been
done during a stimulus stimulus package
with the promise of it being forgiven as
soon as the political tide shifts one
way or the other that will be revisited
and that is just there's no chance I
would step up on that rug and let a
different person coming into the
presidential into the White House or a
different tide in the political climate
happen they forget the promises that
they made when it was stressful
they just do because they they builder
the crap into this stuff and it's just
I'd stay away from it now I don't think
you're gonna run out of cash
that's my prediction because I don't
think you're gonna be shut down as you
know deep into may I do not think that
that the economy can survive that the
the amount of damage done to a hundred
million families at that point would be
devastating and so I just don't think
that that the American public are going
to sit in their homes that long even if
there is a medical reason to do so and I
don't think these governors are gonna be
able to stop them at some point so that
the governors are you know they're doing
the best they can with the information
they've got right now but I I am shocked
that's going on as long as it has but
but there's obviously some good medical
data to get us to this to get us to the
middle of April and then we'll see from
there but it's it's a it's a I wouldn't
want to have the decision-making that
they've got to make I wouldn't want to
have that on me I can't imagine that
those stress of that but the the risk
return ratio on the virus versus the
number of families economic lives being
destroyed is guy at some point
those lines are gonna cross you you need
just hit the on button there there you
go rookie mistake here I'm with the pros
in the studio don't where the buttons
are to turn my mic on Dave this is
really key I've been talking a lot of
business owners and they're saying I
think we're gonna take the grants we're
gonna figure out how to get the grant
it's not one it's a 7a SBA loan there's
a reason they didn't just cut you a
check and so people got to understand
this is a debt there are a lot of
conditions to meet for potential
reimbursement if that comes and you're
increasing your risk to take it and so
no I think it's it's foolish to think
this is free money which is how it's
being talked about out there let's just
pretend that Ramsay Solutions ran out of
cash we would be laying people off
before we would take that it's that
simple
and I don't want to be the worst day of
my life isn't it in 30 years we've never
laid off so far for reasons of economics
and but I'm not borrowing money even
with the promise of it being forgiven
just like I'm not gonna tell you to
borrow money on student loan with the
promise it was gonna be forgiven
remember that promise they made I
remember that promise they made and they
didn't keep it and so I'm just telling
you it now there's gonna be some tax
breaks that you can do you can write off
your your payroll payroll tax and I
would do that for sure I'll be doing
that I had a bunch of that I can write
off but the and anything I can do to
kick that down the road and keep those
actual cash dollars in the building
gives you a longer survival rate along
the burn rate but that's the situation
so no don't borrow the money no do not
step up on the rug no no